how do you stay motivated when you're
starting a business it's a great
question that came in from a YouTube
viewer Yee boys fully boyish full wrote
in my question is how do you stay
motivated when starting a business and
things are not working out especially
when you have a young family to feed
welcome to the club you know what most
people can't get their business beyond
that startup phase where they're
actually making a nice income for
themselves the way to do it the way to
stay motivated
three things gonna give you three advice
this is goal write it down save it
the first is believe in what you're
doing you have to have a bigger goal a
bigger vision a bigger purpose for what
you're doing with your business and that
can fuel you most businesses shut down
not because it wasn't a great idea but
because the entrepreneur gives up too
soon they don't allow time for momentum
to grow into build and some of the
greatest entrepreneurs were failures
like you look at George Lucas started
star wars multi-billionaire his first
six years and his business was a failure
he thought he should go back and get a
job and be practical and listen to his
friends advice he kept going because he
loved what he was doing and he had a
strong belief and passionate it was the
right thing to do you have to find that
with your business it's the most
important thing if you are not there if
you're doing a business just to make
money stop stop right now it's not going
to work go for something that you
passionately believe in and let that
passion fuel you wake up knowing this is
the mission that you are on you are
gonna help people with this specific
problem that can help you it's not the
whole answer because it's still hard
getting up every day even when you
passionately believe in what you're
doing
some days are a lot better than others
okay the next thing that really helped
me was I looked at famous entrepreneurs
I looked up to people who I respected
who I admired and saw that these guys
struggled to like George Lucas and I
think if these guys struggled then I'm I
could be like them too
you know it's not just me it's not like
everybody else's was an overnight
success and I'm the loser who can't
figure it out everybody has a hard time
and I read the stories of people who are
respected who are looked up to for
people who are inside my industry and
outside my industry I've got ideas from
them
I got specific strategies from them but
I also just got motivation from them
when I saw how hard it was for them to
get going and to make this thing work
nobody has that overnight success they
all struggle to get this thing to go so
that gave me extra encouragement
motivation I would start by reading a
story in the morning and it gave me a
little bit of fuel that's why I started
my business my website with the largest
collection of famous entrepreneur
profiles online because I needed that
for my business I needed that to help me
stay inspired and stay motivated and it
still inspires and motivates me and I
wanted to share that with other people
that's why I launched the company so
look to you what I call aspirational
Mentors and get their guidance wisdom
and momentum to help put back into your
business the third thing that really
helped me was customer feedback so when
you see that you're really helping
somebody and you're changing their lives
that should be fuel for you and you may
not be you know making it big yet but
those little stories help keep you going
I remember for me in the early days of
starting this business I've been
Carmical calm I would do events and
webinars and seminars and meet
entrepreneurs and I remember that day
after that the seminar I felt great I
felt wow I just changed these people's
lives they were heading down the wrong
path I I saved them I'm helping to build
a way better business I felt so good
about myself when you help somebody you
feel great and I love I love what I was
doing I felt like this is right like how
could I ever doubt it what I was doing
this is fantastic and then the next day
I wake up and it's gone that feeling of
empowerment excitement is gone I don't
know why you fall asleep you wake up the
next day it's just gone and was hard to
get out of bed so what I did that helped
me was I saved some of the comments that
came back
I saved some of the special emails that
came back
where people write in to say Evan you
changed my life thank you so much please
keep going I can't wait for your next
event and I read those whenever I felt
down whenever I felt low in energy I
read those and they picked me up and
made me realize that you know what what
I'm doing really matters and even if
it's only hitting a few people right now
it matters it's changing people's lives
it's helping them I need to keep going
and that gave me the motivation the
inspiration to just go another day
another day another day you keep
pounding it out so those are the three
things right remember why you're doing
this what your big passion big belief is
look to aspirational mentors people who
you look up to respect and see what they
did and just get their story and plant
it in your head and remember that they
didn't have an easy time either and
three look to your customer feedback see
that you are helping them and change in
the world changing their lives and use
that to feel you to keep going where are
you out right now I feel for you you
know you've got a young family you're
trying to feed them you want to keep
going you want to believe in your dream
and not go back and get a job working
for somebody that you hate you know
doing work that's way beneath you not
living up to your potential and at the
same time you got a balance hey I got
bills to pay I got to put food on the
table these people are depending on me
I'm going to feel guilty if I don't
deliver for them hopefully your family
is supportive of you doing this
initiative but the best thing to think
about right now is I want you to have
that big dream it's great have the big
goal but for now get to survival like
what's a smaller version of that big
dream that gets you to the point of
survival what do you need to make a
month so just to get by I'm not talking
glamorous lifestyle we're not talking
Ferraris and Porsches here I'm talking
like gas money lunch money that's what
you need to survive so you don't go back
and get a job what does that look like
and how can you get there as fast as
possible
that's your first criteria is getting to
survival whatever it takes to get there
and it's not going to be your ideal
company but it makes sure that you are
in business so you don't have to quit go
back get a job and watch some
but he else make huge dollars off of
your idea so figure out what that number
is what you need to survive I need X
thousand dollars a month to survive and
figure out your plan just to get there
while keeping your big goal your big
vision in mind once you get to survival
things can really take off for you
that's your opportunity to blow it up
but you have to get to that point first
believe for those of you watching please
give it a thumbs up below makes me want
to do more for you and I want to hear
what you have to say
leave a comment underneath let me know
if you liked the video or not if you
have a question put it in the comments
I'll make a video response for you thank
you guys I love you we'll see you soon
you